yo um can you give me some insight on
like uh how
influential nipy has been cuz nipy was
kind of the first guy to do the pr pay a
pioner in so many ways nipy is the
reason I decided to start doing proud to
pay and I feel like I revolutionized it
another tier by doing offer base so I
started with proud to pay I was riding
my bike and I was like thinking about
nips $100 album and I was like man how
can I do this but in a way that's
conducive to my people cuz I didn't know
too many [__] who would pay 100 for an
album so I was like I'm just going to
let [__] pay whatever because if I
make $1 over zero then I won right so I
started doing pay what you want and I
one and I end up doing a live show that
was pay what you want and I made less
than I projected but I noticed that
people don't want to pay a certain
amount at the door cuz there's hell
people around so typically some [__]
would give me a rack 100 but you don't
want to do that at the door with people
behind you so I I end up creating offer
base when I start doing my backyard I
was like let's start doing offer base
because I can't I can't set a ticket
price on this experience like you came
to the backyard we had shows with s
there and different people come out so
it's like how can I say man I can't say
this a $20 ticket a $5 ticket $30 none
of that makes sense to me so I'm like
you tell me what what you think this
experience is worth and all I could do
is say yes or no for this one you feel
me and um was it hard to figure out the
back end of the offer based thing
because I've never seen like any website
offer something where you no it was new
with the technology was completely new
like I got what my partner e Brea he
created a a ticketing site called what's
TBA that just sold regular tickets and
when I came I was like man I got this
idea I need to build a tech behind it so
I could do my shows a certain way and we
just started this last year like I said
I did half a million on what's TBA offer
Bas shows last year I think that's the
future if you're smart man it's the
present and going for exactly you
especially when you um when you have a
real live show and a real live
experience and something like me where
you get to holler at me and talk to me
and I'm around like when you know what
it eventually it gets to the point where
people stop offering you L like people
are just like I know what I'm getting
and I know what this [__] is worth and
what it means means to me yeah like if
um certain artists who are like a
certain level end up taking that and
running with it it's going clean up
clean up I even think of like a guy like
you know I always you you always hear a
couple of names Drake Kendrick like if
they ever decided to go independent it
would break the music industry clean up
like if Drake decided to be like clean
up [__] the labels are pissing their
pants he would break the music industry
forever yeah yeah I mean right now
there's a lot of slow work towards that
but that's they know that which is why
they're okay running him half a quarter
billion and plus because they know they
know like he's he's he's responsible for
saving the industry at a at a specific
time so they know yeah like and and I
think of guys like the weekend like the
weekend's team his infrastructure that
isn't the label just his team is so on
point I'm like M yo at what point can
the label do anything but write you a
[__] check that and that's eventually
it gets to that point and I honestly and
truly feel like I'm getting to that
point now like after this run I'm about
to have in
2024 at this point there's not much they
could do but even now the offers I get
is like y'all got to you can only run a
Check and which you should want to when
you see a [__] already got a business
completely established and built all you
want to do is get a cut cuz you don't
have to do nothing you have to do
anything I came to you and said oh you
got a pizza spot let me just give you
some bread and give me a percent every
month that's a win definitely don't have
a pizza spot officially publicly but
maybe soon it it'll be announced on my
Instagram that was like a random you
know I do have a nightclub that's very
successful in Scottdale yeah I se that
yeah shout out to uh my business
partners that perfect example hey man we
tried to get people to invest it was
it's just three of us and uh everybody
who said no within the first month were
like hey can we get in and I'm like [__]
no ah right like cardi B and Meek Mill
and everybody's like yo man look if you
guys still need a second phase of money
I'm like no we're good now like
everybody don't see it everybody don't
see it and and that is the main thing I
think that you're a testament of bro is
cuz these conversations I'm telling you
about that I've had with people right
they don't see it and they don't get it
and they're they're oblivious to like
all you got to do is see it that's all
and people are you know if you believe
in what you're doing and you're sure of
it and you got good people around you
who aren't Yes Men mhm [__] if somebody
who don't like [__] [__] with what what
some an anr thinks [__] with some label
executive thinks like make them see your
vision it'd be tough it'd be tough
because and that's easier said than done
right that's easier said than done man
it's tough to to to stay down cuz you
get offered these SS and you want to go
but it man you really got to stick to
like you got to have a work eth the
other thing is Major label might be for
you if you're lazy yeah I think the ma
your work ethic is insane I think the
majors are necessary because there there
are some artists that are just insanely
talented but they don't have the um the
care or desire to do all the other [__]
to make sure the world I think the
labels are necess even for a [__] like
me like if we find the right label with
the right deal I'm gone cuz I'm already
G is like I'm not on a major and I'm on
every major platform and [__] it's got
to be the right deal though that's it